seit Jahrzehnten gelingt es ja eben
nicht das merken wir auch in diesem
Gespräch immer wieder die großen die
großen Steine zu bewegen im
Bildungssektor die großen Probleme
tatsächlich zu lösen das Vertrauen in
die Politik dass sich da in der Schule
in der Kita wirklich was richtig
Grundlegendes ändert ich glaube die ist
in weiten Teilen der Bevölkerung in
Deutschland dahin
auch ein Grund warum immer mehr AFD
wählen
wir wissen aus vielen Studien das im
Augenblick das Stimmungsbarometer in
dieser Gesellschaft sehr stark von Wut
und auch von der Angst zu Überforderung
und Kontrollverlust geprägt ist und
insofern ist es klar dass bei so vielen
Veränderungen auch die letzten Jahre
Krisen jetzt eine klare Politik auch
gemacht wird die die Menschen nicht
überfordert nicht weil ich die Menschen
nicht für Klugheit die können für sie
selber entscheiden aber indem wir eben
nicht die Anforderungen so hochstellen
dass die Leute die gespart haben oder
die ihren Lebensweg selbst bestimmen
gehen dass wir den jetzt so viele Steine
in den Weg kriegen das selbst bei den
Zielen die wir uns ja alles Gesellschaft
zusammenstellen
natürlich und ich will damit sagen wie
ist denn so die Stimmungslage und was
spielt darauf ein und was ich sagen kann
aber da würde ich nicht den direkten den
direkten Verbindung jetzt zu dem
Wahlergebnis oder den Umfrageergebnis
AFD ziehen was ich spüre ist ich bin
landaufland ab unterwegs und spreche
auch über Forschungsthemen weil ich bin
ja nicht ich bin ja
Bundesbildungsministerin habe aber nur
für die übergeordneten Themen hier
Kompetenzen und bin forschen und ich
kann über Innovation ich kann über
Quantenphysik ich kann überall sprechen
wir landen immer beim Thema Bildung weil
das die Menschen bewegt und ich kann das
auch verstehen und deswegen was glaube
ich muss passieren Jenseits jetzt
kleinen Themen die wir angesprochen
haben sie nicht drei Punkte vertragen
das ich sage auch zu nur drei Sätze ja
dann dürfen sie auch noch Fragen erstmal
ist für mich wichtig dass wir ehrlich
sind nicht alles ist eine Katastrophe in
den Schulen aber die Herausforderungen
sind groß und ich glaube dieses ehrlich
sein und dann sagen jetzt versuchen wir
alle zusammen dran zu ziehen nicht zu
streiten nicht in den Finger auf den
anderen zu zeigen sondern die können wir
die Probleme lösen und das sind die
großen Ziele die Leute sind ja nicht in
naiv die wissen das nicht alles über
Nacht verändert werden kann aber die
wollen sehen das ist erkannt wird und
dass wir den richtigen Weg gehen und ich
glaube das ist eigentlich die
grundvoraus bei allen Pflastern die wir
kleben ich glaube nicht die wollen nur
auch dass erkannt wird aber ich glaube
das ist erkannt ist das Problem die
wollen dass es endlich irgendwann
angefangen wird zu lösen und sie haben
Vertrauen verloren dass das irgendwann
gelöst wird möglicherweise ist es gar
nicht so ungewöhnlich dass sich ganz
viele Menschen dann ein Weg suchen was
anderes auszuprobieren das könnte ein
Grund sein sie haben offenbar in der FDP
ein spezielles Problem damit wir haben
vergangene Woche eine große Umfrage
gemacht im Land und unter mehreren
tausend Menschen und haben einmal
geguckt wer wählt AFD welchen Alters
eigentlich mittlerweile in allen
Altersgruppen in allen Bildungsschichten
sind sehr sehr viele Menschen bereit
eben AFD zu wählen das zeigen dann ja
eben auch dann am Ende Wahlergebnisse
und vor allen Dingen fast jeder zweite
FDP Wähler kann sich vorstellen AFD zu
wählen warum ist das so
wir sehen auch hier dass das sage ich
zum Glück der allergrößte Teil fast 70
Prozent derjenigen die sagen sie können
sich vorstellen AFD zu wählen Sie nicht
wählen weil sie die Partei gut finden
oder glauben dass sie die Lösungen das
sagt Deutschland trennt habe ich nicht
mehr ausgedacht glaube ich auch gar
nicht dass wir dafür damit kann man sich
beruhigen aber nein das ist keine
beruhigen sondern es sind Arbeitsauftrag
das will ich damit sagen es ist ein
Arbeitsauftrag und was die Menschen
nicht wollen ist dass wir sie deswegen
habe ich ja bin ich auch so eingestiegen
eben bei der Antwort dass wir Ihnen
wirklich im Alltag ganz konkret sagen
wie sie zu leben haben wir setzen uns
das Ziel z.B klimaneutral zu werden
natürlich ist das ein Ziel aber wie
genau ich jetzt persönlich mein
Lebensstil darauf zuschneide das sollen
wir Ihnen nicht vorschreiben und vor
allem die Leute wissen auch dass wir
nicht nur einen Weg sondern dass wir die
verschiedenen neuen Technologien nutzen
müssen und das müssen wir ganz klar auch
sagen damit auch das Vertrauen dass wir
nicht jetzt auf kurzes Pflaster kleben
oder
vorschreiben wie du zu leben hast setzen
sondern dass wir durchaus sehen dass
jeder selbstbestimmt zusammen diese dass
wir zusammen diese gesellschaftlichen
Ziele erreichen können und ich möchte
noch eins korrigieren sie haben mich
falsch interpretiert ich glaube nicht
dass wir ein Erkenntnisproblem haben
aber wir haben auch ein Problem uns
ehrlich zu machen als Politik in der
Bildungspolitik und ich glaube das ist
das was die Leute am meisten ärgert dass
wenn sie uns hören und dann die Realität
sehen dass das eben auseinander klafft
so und wenn wir wenn wir wenn das klar
ist
es wird gesehen und dann auch eben
darauf folgt nicht streiten sondern
machen das ist die Grundvoraussetzung
Sonneberg hat sie kürzlich nach die
Landrat gewählt was ist ihre Erklärung
dafür
ja der wir haben es ja vor Ort gesehen
dass die Politik oder der Wahlkampf sehr
stark über Themen gefahren wurden die
nicht unbedingt was mit dem Marktplatz
in Sonneberg zu tun haben sondern andere
Themen und das ist das was ich eben
gesagt habe die Menschen dürfen nicht
das Gefühl haben dass die Politik
nicht sieht was es auch für sie für
anstrengend ist eben zum Beispiel was
ist für finanzielle Bedeutung hat die
die Beschlüsse die wir machen
überfordert sie das oder aber auch ihre
Lebensleistung anzuerkennen nein das ist
ja auch ein Thema im Augenblick belasten
wir die Menschen mehr oder sagen wir
entlasten dich also den einzelnen auch
ernst zu nehmen ist ja auch in der
Demokratie eigentlich selbstverständlich
wir brauchen Bürgerinnen und Bürger das
ist ein bisschen gefragt und kann kann
das Kabinett nicht überall immer
hinfahren aber Sonneberg war ein solch
wichtiger Ort in diesen Tagen es war aus
dem Kabinett niemand dort in Sonneberg
wenn man so wenig über diesen Ort weiß
wenn man immer spekuliert was treibt die
Menschen um warum wählen die in
wlan-draht setzt man sich nicht ins Auto
und fährt einfach mal hin also es ist ja
nicht so dass wir nicht im Land auf und
ab unterwegs sind aber ich sehe schon
auch eine Verantwortung
nicht noch Plattformen zu bieten sondern
gute Politik zu machen was nicht heißt
dass man das Thema nicht ernst nimmt
jeder hat die Verantwortung jeder der
politisch aktiv ist jeder Bürger hat
übrigens auch Verantwortung auch
Wählerinnen und Wähler haben gewesen
wenn sie dort beispielsweise sagen genau
weil man einfach das Thema verstärkt ich
glaube man muss das Thema sehr ernst
nehmen und man muss vor allen Dingen
politisch Antworten
ihr parteiischer verdeutlichen Weimar
bei einer Veranstaltung bei den
Bürgerdialog und hat dann gesagt gibt
das jetzt sinngemäß wieder lieber
Linkspartei wählen als AFD wählen
ja das haben sie jetzt aber sehr
verkürzt weil wenn Sie es genau
angeschaut hätten dann nein wenn sie die
ganze diskussionsbogen anschauen dann
ging es um AFD und er hat vollkommen
recht das sagen auch die sagen auch
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler es ist schon
auch wenn wir sagen wir wollen ein
weltoffenes Land sein wir wollen
Wirtschaftswachstum haben Fachkräfte
Zuwanderung dann ist das natürlich schon
wenn man wenn man natürlich ein Land hat
in dem ähm in dem sagen wir mal der geht
das Gedankengut der Fremdenfeindlichkeit
stark ausgeprägt ist dann ist das ist
das ein Standort Nachteil das muss man
ganz klar sagen und dann ging es darum
um Sozialsystem weil ja oft ähm AFD und
Linkspartei stimmen ja auch ein
Bundestag sehr oft miteinander weil da
geht's um den Versorgung und dann gibt
es ein paar wenige die wissen was für
dich gut ist ja und insofern hat er
gesagt na ja also
das ist im Prinzip hat das gleichgesetzt
also insofern er hat nicht mit nichten
impliziert man solle jetzt oder gibt's
ja noch die Linkspartei hat er nämlich
wortwörtlich gesagt dann kann das
eingefallen
würden sie dann sagen lieber nicht
wählen
nein weil das ist das falsche damit
stärkt man auch die Ränder es ist man
muss nicht verheiratet sein mit einer
Partei es gibt immer Sachen die einem
nicht gefallen aber man sollte es schon
überlegen wo will dieses Land hin und
ich finde das super dass wir wählen
dürfen in unserem Land und dann setze
ich das Kreuzchen doch da wo ich glaube
dass meine Ziele am meisten mitverfolgt
werden was nicht heißt und deswegen
finde ich übrigens auch gut dass wir in
der dass wir jetzt nicht sagen ja na
klar alle Demokraten müssen gute Politik
machen aber wir müssen auch noch
unterscheidbar sein weil eben auch
unterschiedliche Ziele und
unterschiedliche Einstellungen zu
Politik da sind und deswegen muss man
auch ein gutes Angebot machen
unterschiedliches Angebot das Kabinett
geht jetzt in Urlaub sie werden das auch
tun vermutlich in den nächsten Tagen
wenn sie einmal so zurückblicken auf die
letzten anderthalb Jahre wie viel in der
Koalition ist noch Luft nach oben in der
eigenen Leistung
also wir haben in den letzten Wochen
auch noch einiges geschafft im
Hintergrund hinter der Diskussion die
natürlich die Menschen bewegt hat in
unserem
Landung haben wir in 16 Jahren nicht
gesehen Grundlage dafür dass wir
überhaupt Wohlstand erwirtschaften
können und zwar Fachkräfte Einwanderung
und geordnete Zuwanderung genauso
planungsbeschleunigung die jetzt über
den Weg geht wir haben in
Forschungsbereich Dinge auf dem Weg
gebracht also nicht mehr viel Luft nach
oben ziehen sie natürlich
Koalitionsvertrag und vor allen Dingen
also weniger Mikro managementmäßig im
Moment bei 40 bei 90% wo würden sich
einordnen das Kabinett nicht nur sich
persönlich ich glaube mit Blick auf
Außenwirkung ist durchaus müssen wir
zulegen mit Dingen mit Themen die wir
bewegen konnten Jenseits jetzt
vielleicht die Debatte die wirklich auch
viel Schaden angerichtet hat in den
letzten Wochen haben wir schon vieles
auf dem Weg gebracht was nicht passiert
ist in 16 Jahren indem man nur zwei
Partner hatte um sich zu einigen klingt
nach 80%
also mit Blick auf sie müssen nicht mal
vorstellen wir haben eine Krise wir
haben einen Krieg in Europa einen
furchtbaren Angriffskrieg der wirklich
auch alle von neuer Herausforderungen
stellt mein dass wir jetzt die
Bundeswehr neu aufstellen dieses
Sondervermögen das ist in den letzten
Jahren sind unsere Jungs und Mädels da
losgeschickt worden ohne überhaupt die
Ausstattung zu haben also da ist schon
vieles passiert was was im
Paradigmenwechsel also was auch wirklich
nur Umstellung in der Politik bedeutet
ich glaube das müssen wir in Zukunft
stärker machen statt eben zu sagen du
musst ganz bestimmt eine Heizungsart
einbauen ich danke Ihnen für das
Gespräch hier fast eine ganze Stunde
lang bei Bild die richtigen Fragen vor
allen Dingen von unseren Lesern von
unseren Zuschauern danke herzlich Frau
Bundesbildungsministerin Bettina
starkinger danke Ihnen sehr gerne
[Musik]